i am telling the truth
the truth does not matter
there is only the power of men
the first time the four of you sat down
for a table reading i know ben you
talked a little bit about the fact that
jody really brought it actors don't
always do that in a table reading so
sort of the first time you sat down
together joey that wasn't even a table
reading that was just uh in dinner
coming over in jody's i just can't help
myself
she did it as a musical which was
surprising
but it was like a read she had these
really
like good actors make your writing
better always and and to hear her say it
was kind of and it was this moment of
like getting to hear this right is it
going to work it was like oh we're good
it was
brilliant
good actors make you look a lot better
than you are and that was the case with
jody and yeah usually actors are kind of
like there's a sort of reluctance
there's a sort of an underlying like
well i'm not really committing to this
you know i'm just going to talk it
through which it's kind of natural
because you maybe you haven't made all
choices or whatever and you don't really
want to stick your neck out there but it
was definitely emblematic of jody's the
fearlessness that she followed through
with and got a little peek at that early
on jody what do you have to say was that
is that a choice that you often make
like do you um as an actress do you love
to sort of like feel it out in that way
because i know sometimes people like to
hold it back until the day
yeah
honestly i
feel like my emotions are just always on
the surface um but yeah i don't know i
guess honestly i was just so pleased to
be at the table with these guys like to
come on a film of this size and to
admire them all and then for them to be
like do you want to come over and talk
through the script and give us any ideas
and thoughts i was just like oh this is
so lovely and nice such a lovely way
such a collaborative way to work um
so i was just very eager to please it's
the truth
probably a point but when ben and matt
when you wrote goodwill hunting jody i
think you were three i think you were
really young
oh wow
thank you very much
um but you know ben and matt had
somebody said to you back then let's say
the day after you won the oscar you're
not going to write together for another
25 years you're not going to write
together again until 2021. did that
sound about right or would that have
surprised you and then why was this
did you mine a lot of projects over the
years why did this have to be the one i
think if somebody said that to us our
first reaction would be like we got
another job you know
cause really we really wrote good will
hunting to try to get work as actors um
because nobody wanted to hire us and so
it was we wrote it kind of out of
necessity so
um we kind of backed into screenwriting
and we you know we have continued to
work together all the time in the sense
of showing each other our movies are
talking about stuff so it feels like
it's an odd thing to think oh you
haven't worked together you think well
we've done a lot of work together but
this movie in particular was
so it was so self-evident what i mean
it's just the rarest thing in
storytelling to come across this com
incredibly compelling true story about
this phenomenal woman who did
extraordinary things i mean that is the
stuff of classic storytelling so it
doesn't take a good genius to recognize
this is an amazing story and i think
that's the only reason we got nicole oh
yeah oh that's the only way you would
have gotten me out yeah the story wasn't
good i would have just written these
guys off
but they were but this was a project
that i think came to you i think
somebody from your producing team sent
it to you and it took a while to get the
rights to it
so um nicole when you were brought in
um
i'm just wondering because there's not
it made me watching the smell made me
rethink history a lot because we see
history through the lens of males like
now i'm thinking about how stories have
been told over the years probably in our
history books through the perspective of
men and i know there wasn't a lot for
you to go on because there wasn't a lot
written about her i don't even know if
there was a photograph of her anywhere
so
drawing right pre-photo photography yeah
there was a drawing there was a painting
of her but then because of
obviously with time it had um faded and
and and is no more which i thought was
really sad yeah but yeah
perspective like how did you sort of
color in the lines and then also if
there is something that you could have
if there could have been a book written
about her or or if you could have talked
to her what would you have wanted to ask
and what would you want to know
what are you nuts
that's probably what i've
said
and she would have said yeah i am um
what would i ig i don't know i would
tell her that i admire her bravery
and you asked us the first question was
where did she put her rage
i always remember that that was your
first question right um
i you know and um all those movies about
men you know in the past i'm going to
rewrite them all
i am all of them
iowa because it's high time
um but you know i did excuse me um some
research i had a lot of help with
research
um made stuff up because i knew she was
a young woman and you know young women
um
are people and have personalities and
friends and um are good at certain
things and
you know i read about what she might
have been good at um and i knew she
spoke a lot of languages she was very
well educated um
but ultimately traded as you know in a
land deal
and treated like property yeah um
so you know that was fun
jody what would you like to have found
out about her if you could have it's
quite it's quite overwhelming to think
of having that opportunity i would just
hope that
we've
given her justice you know like we've
um
yeah give her a name yeah given her a
voice in a way in which
she
um
felt proud of you know um it's funny
because i watched your performance and i
think well you know everything about her
yeah i mean you obviously it seems to me
like
you know you must understand it is
imbued it with such evident humanity and
it's so fully realized it seems like
you have no question i guess that's the
but the trick of good acting
yeah well i guess that's also is is why
you choose your roles right i feel like
unless you get that instinct or that
draw or it you know it has to provoke an
emotion in you you have to relate to
something within yourself in some way
whether it's like on the surface or not
um i think it's how you usually choose
choose your roles when i'm curious about
the dynamic of filming it did you shoot
it in succession because this is
obviously in three parts or how did you
shoot how did ridley stage it like was
it you know like for the bedroom scene
for example did you sort of shoot it all
together and then how do you reconcile
that as actors when you're making these
different shifts
um yeah so the the the scene from the
the front door to the bedroom we
we shot the hallway and up the stairs up
to the bedroom door
as one section and then the bedroom was
it
was its own um thing
um and i think they were shot on
separate days okay so you had time to
sort of make that shift
yeah but there were days that we would
do oh yes
different versions of you know because
we were in the same location it's not
like we would return to a location you
know because you're you're it's a it's a
cost thing so we'd shoot three different
scenes in a day and they each when we'd
have to say to each other okay wait we
got to remember this is this is my
version or this is your version because
you're playing really kind of three
roles you're playing how you see
yourself in one version and then you're
playing how the other characters see you
in their versions of the story right and
also ridley uses so many cameras at the
same time so he shot those rape scenes
in one take
yeah so
watching it was like watching somebody
getting raped there was no cut and pace
there was no redo it was just from
beginning to end and it was incredibly
moving and disturbing
i'm curious ben did you ever consider
playing a different role did matt did
you and ben ever consider as you were
writing it playing different roles and
why did you i mean he's a delicious
character and you play him brilliantly
why was why did you decide on playing
him i mean two interesting one yes
originally i had considered playing the
degree part i really had a certain
window i was filming a movie that was
dangerously close to that on both sides
so schedule wise it was going to be
tough and also
when i looked at it i thought you know
and it's it's interesting it's kind of
been reflected this is i
felt like the sort of the amount the
familiarity we have with actors now from
social media to you know the access that
we have gives us a kind of intimacy with
them that where we bring all this
baggage to it and the idea was like well
maybe this we don't want this sort of
whatever the idea of the like matt and
ben and our long association or why he
gets first billing in that association
which is always bad for me
rather than rather than the movie
whereas
um this character was also very fun and
i thought but fun in a way that was like
playing somebody you know
the effect who empowered because i had
noticed
uh you know i didn't grow up knowing any
powerful people at all i didn't know
what that was like you know you know i
didn't
right so i didn't know any powerful
people and so i didn't know like what is
it like to be at the fraternity at yale
and this is the president and he's going
to be a ceo of this or that and then
when i went and grew up and met some
people like that one other thing i
noticed was there was a kind of if you
feel that you're just you know afforded
this power by birth by nature of who you
are a dent of who you are there's this
kind of glib oddly cavalier sort of well
it doesn't really matter i'm just in
charge of it i make it up kind of thing
and i rather than being a mustache
twisting i thought that's an interesting
thing to bring to this he's not aware um
of of of you know desiring to be evil
and make bad decisions is he just
self-interested like a lot of people and
sees the world through the lens of his
own experience but didn't you i mean
wasn't there an original duel when ben
and matt you were kids where ben you
jumped in and saved matt from a fight in
the school yard wasn't it that happened
so often
i mean over and over it happened once
with this dude named
i probably shouldn't say his name but he
was six foot six and on say his name no
no no the poor guy's probably
he's a wonderful
guy
uh and uh we were playing football uh in
the snow and uh i said something stupid
to him i totally provoked him and uh
and he attacked me and and i i remember
being on the ground and i just shelled
up i was like this is gonna be bad
and uh little ben affleck 5-1 just
flying through the air and tackled this
dude off and then everybody jumped in
and broke it up but i was like wow this
dude this dude will put himself in a bad
situation for me like i gotta keep this
guy around a second
not by me not by me
never by me
um i want to talk about the duel scene
that you know ridley is obviously a
masterful director at staging action
maybe
asking sort of each of you ben as a
director
what did you take from that experience
with him i think he said which is crazy
because he you know directed gladiator
that it was the toughest
experience he's ever had and then i
think matt he made you you know he put
you through your paces he made you
physically do it no stunt doubles
nothing
what i would say is that's just entire
technique i mean i the only way i've
learned to do any of this stuff is just
by watching people better than me at
stealing from them and copying them and
admiring them and in this case i really
came away impressed with his style of
filming where you know he gets so much
more done it all happens at once it
feels alive as an actor there's a sense
of urgency we're all on camera it's not
like you're doing your close-up with the
other actress texting you know and you
and you don't know what they're seeing
it's brilliant and it was really
exciting and so
i i would like to you know um borrow
that whole way of doing things and and
because it's it's just really it really
i think serves the story really really
well and the duel we just knew he this
is like something that he quite clearly
is brilliant at and so he says okay but
this is what happens make it great but
the duel itself we had to change from
what happened historically because they
it was very uncinematic i mean it it it
progressed exactly as it does in the
movie from horseback to the ground to
access to swords to daggers that all
happened but we had this amazing stunt
coordinator named rob inch and his team
and they choreographed this this duel
and beautifully and we and while while
adam and i did the duel like these stunt
guys were there
i mean they basically walked us through
and it's just audiences are so smart now
it's really hard to get away with
with putting stunt people in and so when
the actors can do it you know like we we
it's it's the best for us to kind of do
the do the choreography but um but it's
really that's all down to ridley and to
and to rob and to those that stunt team
for kind of building that duel i think
they did don't sell yourself short
adam's a lot younger than you he's a lot
younger
i was way more tired
definitely
one thing i i think was is phenomenal
about this film is that four days later
i'm still thinking about it and still
thinking about you know that idea of
you know we don't think see things as
they are we see things as we are and
also the idea of you know you're all
actors where with this episode of nicole
where your work is constantly getting
judged and people are discussing it so
you have that self-awareness
oh yes i'm acting right now i'm acting
right now by the way so
that's right that's right um but sort of
um jody if you can maybe talk about and
nicole what do you what do you
conversations do you hope people take
away from this film i just hope it
provokes thought amongst people um
personally on a much broader level i
also hope that people in like are moved
by this film you know
um
it's a spectacle it's it's beautiful it
has heart it has the stunts it has so
much so ultimately i hope they
enjoy it and are moved by it and but i
think there's a lot of important issues
you know especially in regards to
marguerite's experience and
and hopefully it forces people to think
a little bit more about maybe the
actions that they've made themselves i
think definitely holds a mirror up to us
all you know um
which i think is a is a good thing
well said i can't imagine adding
anything else
um a lot except we got to see this again
that's what we want yeah yeah
um and and just as we wrap up um a lot
of course the internet has been talking
about your appearances in the film and i
don't mean it i have more fake hair
than you guys had in the entire film but
how did your costuming really is so
detailed i really felt it how did your
costuming everything inform each of your
performances
well ridley sent us those looks that he
was very specific about it ben can speak
about his
the the platinum blonde about and and
how it and what it and what it says and
and how it differentiates him but my the
idea behind my my look and that kind of
mullet look that ridley loved is the guy
was remembered as a really savage
warrior still today he's remembered 600
years later very violent man very who he
loved he loved to fight and he went and
fought for france whenever he could and
so ridley liked the idea that he
wouldn't have time for like a haircut
he'd just take a knife and and shake and
rip the sides off and throw his helmet
on and kind of go and so that and the
scar and the the whole kind of look was
really designed ridley had this idea
along with uh our hair and makeup
department and they kind of they kind of
put it together and and i like that i
mean people you know it's getting some
grief on the internet i i think but but
the idea what is that it's not supposed
to look good the idea you know i hate
those movies when you see him and it's
like you can tell what decade it was
made because like it's medieval times
but sometimes somehow the guy's got 80s
hair and you're like why does he look
like he just got a blow dry you know
like it should look like it did like
like it wasn't professionally done it's
dirty and these guys lived close to the
ground you know when eric talked in the
book about the winter being evil and
hard and that's how they described the
winter that meant people were going to
die you know what i mean it's like there
was no guarantee we're going to survive
a tough winter like these guys lived
very very close to the ground and and
the look the look needed to reflect that
and for me yeah really is very visual
director and very specific and
approaches it's interesting different
directors have found like you can kind
of identify if you're asking like what
was the first job you had from this
editor writer actor director you know um
and and you know
women and men who direct movies can be
you know kind of
are always it's the way you always kind
of are where you come from on some level
like you know how did you started
writing is that what you like as a
director right was your entree into it
yeah i didn't think i was going to be a
director yes
you know her movies are so literary and
so
you know what people say and what they
say to one another i think it's what
pushes them and ridley as a as a product
designer the camera operator has a very
visual as a
painter yes and painted the storyboards
and he said you know max foncito the
seventh seal i want him to feel
scandinavia and i've had this butt at
first i thought oh my god people are
gonna this is the same like but you know
when you have a director like ridley who
you really trust if it's somebody who
was their first movie that i would go
like i don't know are you trying to make
a joke out of that yeah it would be hard
to you know
completely i might you know but i when
you work with really talented people
part of that process and collaborating
is trusting them and saying it's going
to work and kristen berkey who who made
the wig and the italian people who did
all the the hairs sort of one by one
individually like worked really hard and
in part to try to differentiate us from
what people's associations are with us
that they have from over the years and
other movies and the internet and so on
and and also to grounded in some realism
this sort of bold cut caesar thing and
you know yes it looks a little silly now
because you know fashions and haircuts
and stuff change and i agree with matt
you know it's like it was 77 and so it's
or you know it's it's it's uh the middle
ages but everyone else the bee gees you
just dates the movie you know but you're
so right like if you if you guys
wouldn't have transformed then it would
have been the fact that you didn't you
know it's like it's it's can't get a
break
the penalty
for bearing false witness
is that you are to be burned
alive
i would not be silent